addressing myself this time to a perhaps
somewhat unusual topic at least unusual
in some circles because more than most
topics that we tend to consider here it
is I think frequently misunderstood
misrepresented and both on the positive
and the negative side treated in an
unreasonable manner so what is magic
first of all it's believed the term
magic is derived from an old indo-aryan
root ma 3 mug which in all the languages
vary to curse has something to do with
greatness even in English we have such
terms as magnitude magnification and so
forth so it has to do with an expansion
with an enlargement even the world
magnet has something to do with it
because it was named at the Greek island
of Magnus well there was a lot of
magnetic oil and people would see the
magnetic oil how it draws onto itself
smaller pieces of iron and thereby
enlarges so it all has to do with that
enlargement enlargement of what
enlargement of consciousness enlargement
of the soul attaining to a magnification
of our essential selfhood this is the
essence of magic and so from a certain
time on in history disciplines and they
at least a basic worldview surrounding
these disciplines came about in many
different cultures it by no means
confined to the Mediterranean culture or
to various cultures of Asia but it can
be found everywhere these disciplines
developed that are oriented toward that
kind of an expansion why because the
need to expand
or consciousness the need to widen our
soul as you lost I know called it was
white when desi lay got a nice metaphor
is an essential longing an essential
instinctual underlying desire in the
human being
in fact most other preoccupations and
desires that we have are in a certain
sense materialized metaphors for that we
think that we want a lot of money and
what is that but an enlargement well of
our bank account of our stock portfolio
or whatever the case may be but this
very well may be and in fact I think it
is a certain distortion of an other
desire which we are not conscious of
because its character is of a much more
subtle nature and that is the expansion
of our soul we are in need of expanding
our consciousness much more than we are
in need of expanding our bank account
yet with the extra version of
consciousness as you would have called
it we project this much more subtle
interior need on to the external world
and we think that we need things we
think that we need external objects and
yet how many of these objects can we
really use there is a obvious limitation
to the accumulation of externals but
there is no limitation not even the sky
is the limit to the expansion of the
soul so people have not only felt and
believed but known for a very very long
time and in many many places and it was
to respond to this great internal need
this longing that magic came to be
designed and came to be devised so the
very first thing
the very first important concept that we
need to keep in mind in connection with
magic is that it's true aim is the
expansion of our interior nature and
that everything else that people
ordinarily associate with magic is
really but a byproduct and often the
distortion of that now we also need to
keep in mind a few other concepts
without which we will never understand
this peculiar field one of the most
important of these is that the religious
spiritual effort and kind of the map of
the greater realm of being into which
our consciousness is designed to invest
in to expand varies from time to time
going to various factors which we don't
need to consider here because they sort
of have to do with the cultural history
of the West we have come to a gross
oversimplification of the religious and
spiritual worldview we have come to
think that to the extent that we are
religious at all that here we are and
there is God and these are the two
things that matter and in that world our
selves first in God second of course but
that religion and the religious effort
is a mere simple interaction between the
individuals consciousness the individual
soul and the ineffable ultimate reality
of God and that there is nothing in
between a very peculiar notion it's a
notion that comes from the intellectual
inflation that has come upon us in the
course of our history since about the
Renaissance but gradually but somehow
all the ancient peoples including the
people who are our
ancestors within Western culture knew
better than that they envisioned a vast
and really in many ways very exciting
very fascinating region between
ourselves here in the manifest external
reality and the ultimate reality a great
in-between world that is filled with its
own flora and fauna is filled with
angels and less highly developed
spiritual beings planetary spirits all
kinds of entities within their own
regions within worlds upon worlds upon
worlds and the usual assumption was that
when we came here originally rather when
we were born or whether in reincarnation
according to a reincarnation or pattern
perhaps eons ago prior to our series of
embodiments here we came through this
vast landscape and if we are to go back
we need to go back through that
landscape again now it is this
intermediate landscape between ourselves
and ultimate reality that is addressed
by magic it cannot be addressed in a in
a physical way we have no physical means
of travelling in a non-physical region
so it has to be addressed by means of
consciousness by means of the spirit by
means of the mind and this view was
virtually universal at least in the the
higher and deeper aspects of religiosity
right up to the modern era when our
obsession with the external the
extroverted world has sort of replaced
it and pushed it out of the way now then
so it is by way of thus extending ours
into these deeper regions that our
consciousness that our self who grows
and if you want to pinpoint the
particular philosophical schools and
disciplines from which this tradition
has descended to our culture then we can
reply merrily to the Alexandrian period
of the Mediterranean culture namely from
about 300 400 or so BC until 3 or 400 AD
along the shores of the Mediterranean
and particularly centered in the
Egyptian the Graco Egyptian great city
of Alexandria and we will find there
such people as the neo-platonists the
Gnostics the Hermit assists who were all
magicians particularly in the 19th
century in the late 18th and 19th
century and through a good deal of the
early part of the 20th century d the
magical orientation of these people was
not emphasized very greatly in our
literature by our historians and by
various scholars they were all called
philosophers but we need to keep in mind
that philosophy the love of wisdom
certainly included magic as far as these
people were concerned
neoplatonist let's say of the kind of
umbilicals supercruise would have
considered it laughable to study the
philosophy of Plato or of protein as
ammonia's without doing something about
it the notion that just thinking about
things will produce Titanic changes in
reality or in our own internal reality
was not considered a viable proposition
to these people I knew otherwise
gentlemen the played professor earnest
would the first man ever to write about
the Seven Rays for instance about the
full 11 years before Alice B
professor would was want to say you know
one thing you have to remember is that
thinking leads only to more thinking
thinking is self-perpetuating the mind
keeps churning out more ideas more
concepts more images but thinking by
itself hardly ever leads beyond itself
but this is something that we have
managed to forget so with these kinds of
basic ideas in the back of our minds
first of all realizing that magic is
well that goes almost without saying at
least in this place that magic is not
pulling rabbits out of hats that is the
stage magic that came about as a clever
imitation of certain magical phenomenon
that neither is magic just causing
phenomena to occur in the external world
whether it is healing an illness as I
mentioned before or whether it is
beating up our enemy some people would
call one of these white magic in the
other one black magic but that these are
all terrific external at the heart of it
all is an endeavor to expand to widen
our consciousness and to widen it in the
direction of ultimate reality
recognizing however the intervening
realms of beings through which
consciousness must travel in order to
reach ultimate reality five now we will
get away from this theory to something a
little more concrete how are we going to
study this field the best way to do so